hey everybody and welcome to a forgiving
wild ride with stevo we're looking back
at the past with roman atwood and we're
just coming to terms with some things
that weren't that great and we're moving
forward in a positive way it's a good
thing
and speaking of forgiveness
ah man
my wiener does not let my girl off the
hook for one
second
after i chew up my bluetooth tablets
there is no forgiveness when i chew up
my bluetooth tablets my wiener has
declared war with lux's vagina and
that's how it is now what is a bluetooth
tablet it's a delicious chewable tablet
that contains the same active ingredient
as both viagra and cialis except they
only cost a fraction of the price this
is it baby bluetooth tablets give you a
major boner and i love using them and my
girl lux really loves it when i use them
too now of course they do require a
prescription but fortunately when you go
to bluechew.com you easily and quickly
consult with one of their medical
providers right there on the website and
you're taken care of very fast with the
bluetooth tablets in the mail what's
even better is that bluetooth loves the
listeners of the wild ride podcast so
much they're ready to give you an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets
completely for free all you gotta pay is
five bucks for shipping i mean you can't
beat it i love it i swear by it i think
you're gonna love it too so go to
bluetooth.com
and use the promo code stevo to get an
entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets absolutely for free all you pay
is five bucks for shipping you and your
boner are gonna thank me so hop to it
and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen
roman atwood
hey guys dude listen
i don't lose sleep for a lot of people
i was freaking pumped for this man like
so stoked well dude um i i was itching
to get you on and here we are on my tour
bus in ohio and uh you reached out
i was thrilled super thrilled it's such
an honor and dude i couldn't even
believe it i was like
so excited i said i texted you
wait to get a load of the tour bus and i
sent you a picture of our setup and you
said i watched dave england take a dump
on that i did it was like the last thing
i watched and i'm like i'm like whoa
dude roman's actually like watching that
was at the end of that episode of course
dude it's crazy man what a sick setup uh
you gotta show people this like you need
to show people your setup i have so much
more respect for your setup you've got
cameras hanging from the ceiling you've
got scott rocking it with the mixer on
his lap like this is
this is like full optimization of what
you do for sure man it's inspiring
it's it's tripod free these days which
which i'm super stoked on that's so cool
and uh i mean yeah it's a
it's a piece of [ __ ] rv which we've
disguised as a tour bus and we have
problems with it all the time
but uh i i love to hate it and i [ __ ]
just love love it that's the rv life
yeah they fall apart that's what they do
but it looks dope there's no discreet
right boss here this is like dude i
go back and forth on regretting
the obnoxious rap with my face and name
all over the bus
we got a custom-made led sign on the
door that says it's not okay to knock
please do not disturb
that's it but the rest is so welcoming
some people knock
have we already had knockers we've had
knockers
wow okay but the sign wasn't on
yeah there was there's a lot lizards man
they can't resist exactly it was just a
good tour bus it's all good though man
because when we're driving down the road
and we're here like
like
all these people absolutely it's wrong
everybody knows there's no way you don't
it's like it's yeah it's really rad but
uh so dude when was the last time i saw
you it was uh like 2015 or something
gosh no way has it been that long
was when you did the p video with uh
bobby lee was in it too bobby lee video
dude
your insight on editing would really
impressed me when we made that people
video yeah i was like yo roman i want to
steal your idea and do the
the fake peeing with the water bottle
and uh i remember you you helped us turn
that around and uh and get it out like
in
the shot at the one day and they can put
it out the next day i feel like we came
out here when you balance the
the the ceiling and the drop of the
water on your blog we dropped a knife
from the ceiling into my mouth on your
kitchen
yeah yeah right here yeah we've actually
done more than than i thought you've
been here
maybe a couple times i've been here a
couple times because i don't think that
was the new house i think that when we
dropped the knife into my mouth it was
the old house yeah for sure for sure i
don't think that you could drop a knife
from a ceiling into your mouth sad times
man
youtube's become considerably more
sensitive since then you also taught my
boy noah how to juggle uh which was cool
he's 17 now what yes sir
he is a man almost and wow yeah do you
keep cranking out kids like it's not
just i'm a little human factory
you had you he's your oldest right you
had him when you were 21
uh yeah 23 how old are you now
39 man wow
we're the same age
39 yeah
it's it's insane man time is evil
and especially evil when you watch uh
your loved ones growing my daughter
turns five tomorrow wow and it's the
most precious thing in my life and she's
so excited to turn five and i'm just
heartbroken so i just wanted to stay
four forever crazy yeah time's evil goes
fast man yeah
um now i i remember
that you at a certain point
like being that you're like the the
godfather of vlogging right i mean
it was you and shea carl yeah shea was
old casey neistat casey crushed it that
that you guys were all doing it like
yeah you had like the jesse wellins and
jesse and early like the early guys were
like the shay carl the charles trippy
they were like the oh geez you know
right
and i kind of
you know i jumped in and happened to
do well i mean dude it's insane because
i remember like the the the whole prank
you know phenomena was going on in like
in year 2013 when i met you guys
and
you were just committed to doing the
daily vlogs as well
and the vlogs just
took off like and and you just were over
the pranking right it was the most risky
move i did
because coming from nobody and all of a
sudden you're this big prankster on
youtube that's like you think it's your
jackpot that's your goal that's where
you're gonna live forever and i remember
like
making the call to my management into
youtube like hey not only am i going to
move to vlogging which was a crazy risk
i'm going to go pg and i was family
friendly yeah from rated r to family
friendly
was so risky and scary and i was i
remember uploading sweating like i was
freaking out
yeah and in hindsight the timing of that
was so
beautiful like you just kind of stepped
away from pranking before that whole
ship just [ __ ] i saw it coming and i
really
i can't take that much credit but i've
really seen something coming it was
becoming so saturated and it was filling
up with so much
and i could see youtube starting to
crack down a little bit and i was like
guys
you got to evolve like i i warned
everybody
and you know the vlogging stuff
it was so fun to me and it was also
really who i was i got to really be me
pranking sometimes was awkward for me i
didn't always feel comfortable that's
why i had guys like vitali and dennis
and these guys that love going out there
doing crazy crap yeah i was like a
cameraman and an editor really at the
end of the day
it's like filming my life my wife my
family was like that's actually who i
was so it felt real and good
right and and and
by going pg
i mean god that just changes the whole
dynamic on on the the business side of
youtube right i mean i for me
the uh ad revenue just
has always been like borderline
negligible because like the stuff i put
out is not family friendly and and it is
what it is but didn't you start like a
whole youtube network
to like like your own mcn kind of thing
a multi-channel network i didn't i
didn't uh but shea did
she call had the big uh network he
started making make her yeah and he
killed it yeah he killed it you didn't
do that were you talking about doing it
or no i thought [ __ ] i thought i
remembered that no i i probably had
conversations about it for sure because
in my in my like
rise that was the thing to have so i
absolutely probably discussed it but
you know once makers sold it was like
the uh that did make her even oh they
sold to disney yeah and then after
disney got it didn't it just dissolve
and fail i don't remember hearing about
it after that i don't know if you
changed it i don't know they bought it
for like 500 million right i think it
was some crazy number some crazy number
that made shaycarl a very rich man and i
think that as far as i mean we're
probably losing listeners by uh talking
about the business of maker studios but
i think it just straight failed
and didn't turn into anything
i think it just disappeared yeah and
some of them companies buy out threats
too like if it was literally like could
be threatening their content or
viewership
it's like uh it's like shelf space right
like you buy the competition there's an
upcoming drink
you're taking my shelf space we just buy
it i think uh that's been the model of
like the ufc they've bought all the all
these fight organizations
yeah um so was doing daily vlogs for you
kind of like when casey neistat was
talking about like if they weren't in
your
like script you couldn't hang out with
them you couldn't do certain things with
certain people he said like like he
he would be insulted by someone saying
hey let's go out to lunch like and not
film it like what yeah
oh it changed my whole life because yeah
you got not only are you from you got
camera in somebody else's face all day
so you know your mom and dad and your
bro everybody i filmed everything dude i
know it was annoying but everybody dealt
with it well and and going pg was
another double-edged sword because it's
really hard to be funny pg
it's it's for me it's easy or for me
to be crude and get that that those dad
jokes are just funnier when they're
crude so go on pg was tough for me so i
fell onto that family content but you
got rad too i remember when you were
like okay now i'm going to learn how to
do a backflip on a motorcycle like that
with travis pastrana yeah i pretty much
did what i loved to do and kept it clean
i saw uh
did i i mean dude you've been on fire
like
recently with like
just all different like
contraptions and just like i'll be like
commenting on your instagram like dude
this is the most like
creative
[ __ ] you know i love it thank you man
yeah just i think that like i mean i
wouldn't even necessarily put you in uh
like a pg basket because like this is so
much the stuff you do is just straight
crazy it's like a trap here's the weird
part um
all my kids that watch me they're all
adults now
i've done it long enough now that i
don't have any no kids know who i am
it's all these high schoolers and
college guys that come up to me i
watched you when i was a kid
and that was my very first step to
starting a podcast i realized i'm still
making this kids i'm still blowing up rc
cars and i don't have anybody watching
it anymore they want they want real life
they want business advice they want to
be inspired they want to learn how to
live life
so i've started to to fade from my kid
audience you know right now i have full
grown adults listening that's crazy man
it really makes sense dude i have this
buddy in uh
tampa he's like the biggest radio dj his
name's mike calta and i just love this
guy like we get together and go to
dinner and [ __ ]
and uh there was a point
where he was like dude my son
like is
like losing his mind like roman atwood
like he's just he's so crazy about roman
atwood and i think at some point i was
trying to like link you guys up but but
i don't know if it worked out
and um and and i think that like what
you're saying adds up because he's
you know
the kids growing up and like
maybe you went through like logan paul
or so you know like and then yeah it's
crazy like to have kid audience
and it it's it's so weird for me because
i feel like i get older they just stay
the same age for me you know yeah
yeah you yeah dude
i could go on and on about how you've
inspired me um
just infinitely infinitely many we were
chatting we were chatting uh with uh
aaron out front talking about how
youtube started how jackass was before
that and how well didn't youtube start
as like a dating thing
i think i do have that right that
youtube started as a dating thing and i
got something to tell you about dating
i'm in a relationship of course with lux
and to strengthen my relationship i
decided to get into therapy and i
couldn't be more glad that i did and i
couldn't be more glad that this episode
is brought to you by betterhelp.com
which is your one-stop shop for all of
your therapy needs where you'll find an
entire network of professional
accredited therapists who can help you
with whatever it is you're hoping to
work on and i can't speak highly enough
about how much being in therapy is
helping me
um not only with my relationship with
lux but also in just addressing things
like my out of control diet like my
email box like anything that's giving me
stress i speak up about it and next
thing you know i'm addressing it so it's
just helping me immeasurably and i'm
very happy to pass on this message to
you guys and a big discount if you go to
betterhelp.com
stevo they're gonna give you ten percent
off your first month plus keep in mind
that the therapy you get through better
help is easier to set up you can do it
remotely and it's way more affordable
so them giving you 10 on top of that is
epic i say take care of your mind
go to betterhelp.com
stevo and
check out how well you can match people
up with precisely what you're looking
for you can find the perfect therapist
for you
and that's what i did again i'm very
happy i did i hope that you get this
better help
h-e-l-p
so please do and let's talk about
youtube
it definitely wasn't what it is now yeah
yeah for sure but dating thing i think
it was like a dating thing they were
trying to like i i thought that somehow
jackass was like an inspiration to the
people who started youtube but then i i
i got into some like
documentary about youtube
on youtube
and it was like i think that if i
remember correctly it was like oh it was
some dating deal and they just had a
video component so that you could
like
like upload videos of yourself so you
introduce yourself to potential dating
partners interesting
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah so i
mean i i i don't know but but yeah it's
rad i mean
the the whole way the the world has
changed with uh technologies is insane
um i remember when we
were here last
you were running a merch operation out
of your garage and you had all of your
family like packing up the
you know the parcels and shipping them
out and everything yeah and i remember
scott and i being struck that you had
only like one
item just the smile more shirt yeah and
that was it and i think they were all
like royal blue and like and like no
other colors yeah and i remember like us
thinking man like i wonder like
why even back then we were like man
every time we add a new piece of merch
like our sales just go up you know did
you ever end up like diversifying your
mercy so here's the funny part
um we just recently moved the company to
texas okay um i've i've partnered with a
close friend of mine we own bunker
branding and we actually run merch for
50 different influencers so our our so
it's a fulfillment house our companies
fulfill we also produce all the product
in-house so you have a you have a viral
idea that shirt can come out that day on
your
on your website right so a quick but the
funny thing with smile more which is
this logo still to this day
we tried forever to release new art and
the only thing that would sell was our
plain white smile more logo it was like
our nike swoosh it's like the only thing
people wanted was that brand it's like i
branded it
as that logo not necessarily the word
smile more right i mean it's it's a
great thing i mean it's hard to see
smile more and and not feel good it fit
with my with who i am and and you know i
always just try to inspire people i want
i want people to have a better life and
smile more was me for real so it's
always been fun to push that yeah but
just recently as in
two months we're starting to drop new
art and we're testing it so
i'm pumped to move forward but man i'm
telling you we branded it so hard is
that logo it's hard to like
you know dude we
struggled so much selling apparel
for the for the longest time and it's
just it drove me nuts because with i've
got books i've got skateboards and stuff
and all these things that we sell i'll
sign everything i spend like so much
time signing merch to sell and it's the
signatures that i put on the merch that
actually make
the the thing sell and like the t-shirts
that i don't sign it's just like they
just [ __ ] sit in the warehouse and
collect dust and it drove us nuts until
we tried the new model which which uh we
heard great things about from other
podcasters where you present a shirt
design you say this is limited we're
taking orders for the next
you know seven days you can pre-order it
now then
because people know that after those
seven days it's never going to exist
again there's an urgency to get it so
they buy it like crazy we take the
orders for seven days and then
we turn around a production run super
fast and ship them out and no overhead
because you know how many you've done
you're not getting you're not gonna
you're you're gonna print as many as
you've already sold and uh and we've
done it twice so far and finally i feel
like we've cracked the code yeah that's
awesome that's exciting
with with your model it sounds like a
little bit of like a teespring model
right
yeah we're we're playing around with
that same concept though with the
pre-orders
nobody seems upset that they have to
wait a few weeks to get the birthday
dude don't make them wait a few weeks
pre-order like this is coming out next
month
you know yeah well
i think you got to get a a
like that scott can answer this better
but like we're we just finished uh a
pre-order window
yesterday it was like a rapid prototype
right now
and and the other thing that's great
about it too because we've got this like
pretty substantial company that that uh
produces and and um distributes to to
retailers so they're like they know
what's up 12 color silk screens no
problem you know like
it looks like a photo that's amazing
yeah huge operation and um
what's good about that is that it's not
like heat transfer [ __ ] you know
we're turning it around we're printing
every [ __ ] pre-ordered shirt like
today and they're all like high level
silk screen and we'll have them out with
you know seven days that's awesome seven
days what yeah yeah
obviously speed is everything right
the signature thing uh you remember when
i filled my house with those plastic
play balls sure i fronted 40 grand for
them balls and at that time it was so
hard for me to do
and i remember freaking out like how do
i pay these balls off like i need to
capitalize on these balls so i did the
same thing i'll sign
everybody that places an order i'll sign
a ball wow and it was like
instantly sixty thousand dollars like we
paid the balls off instantly everybody
got a ball sign it was just like such a
fun story of like how well that
signature worked yeah and how quickly it
was like instant dance yeah i mean were
you broke at the time or i wasn't broke
but
i mean
roman's been killing it for a long time
yeah
but that that video single-handedly
changed my whole career so it was before
that um i certainly had the income to
pay it but coming from broke i was
always so scared to spend sure 40k for a
wing i have no idea if this is gonna be
a hit right it's like a risk i think
that as a rule
if you for me
like if i'm
investing because that's all i do you
know it's like uh it's like oh man you
know like i'm gonna do a podcast let me
buy a crazy expensive sprinter van yeah
best purchase i ever made yeah and then
it's like oh i'm on tour now i've
graduated to theaters like renting a
tour bus sucks let me buy a piece of
[ __ ] rv best move i ever made you know
like and and and production-wise like
i've spent insane amounts of money to to
produce like you know big stuff and
every time i've bet on myself in that
regard it's it's worked out yeah i think
any time that you invest putting money
back into your career so that you can
give
better quality
like content like uh
like stuff like then it's always a good
make your money make money i was reading
this stat today the like the two most
sexiest things a man can do is
one have like veins popping out of his
arms and yeah it was like it was like
really attractive for women to see veins
and then another one is being a
successful risk taker like risking it
and then like being successful
thank god he prioritized veins first
it's just those two things it's pretty
wide range
and also you hit a point where
especially in our field you've got to
have tax write-offs right we have so
little overhead on youtube
you have to my account when i really
started making money it was
abs it was absurd
he would he would literally call me like
you have to spend
this much money this week or you're
giving it to the government so it would
just force us to blow money
it was like we would just buy everything
we need was a new work truck
a skid steer for the property we just
blow money
and it's like these type of things those
are expenses you write off help avoid
taxes they're all business expense they
grow your company i don't think i have
any trouble whatsoever uh spending money
that because i mean like
we put money into production and that's
you know
like i i you'll see tonight and by the
way i'm so excited that you're coming to
my show so yeah like i'm so pumped we
i'm [ __ ] flying around all over on a
helicopter dangling from a rope
this is big then yeah because you know
where the last time i saw your show was
yeah it was a big bar it was nice yeah
it was it was a comedy club yes
nice club but it sounds like you're i
mean this is something i filmed for like
uh but my show now is multimedia so in
the opening sequence i'm like [ __ ] on
the roof of the house and this
helicopter drops a rope bladder and i
grab it i'm flying around like crashing
through all this [ __ ] the [ __ ]
helicopter flies over this tour bus and
i'd drop off the rope ladder and land on
the roof of the moving tour bus oh my
god and then it's like the tour bus like
takes me to the theater and and that's
how you can see you watch so you see
that and then you walk out watch me get
to the show yeah man yeah the last show
you were at was the ice house pasadena i
think it might be it might be then we
all went out after yeah it might be
yeah i mean whatever it's great we've
known each other for a good amount of
time and i'm excited to to really get
into how much you changed my life
on your podcast which is new and that's
kind of like just hearing that seems
impossible uh i know dude it's it's
insane like i mean
and not just you you were the first you
know you were the first to to to launch
me into the digital space at a time when
i thought that that was like a terribly
depressing demotion
i was like dude i'm a
big time movie star man like i've been
in like three number one movies like
i've had my own tv shows but now i'm
gonna like
uh upload a youtube video
yeah yeah i could see that sound yeah
and i had i swallowed my pride i was
like and and dude thank god it's like
you saved my life you know i mean you
brought about a rebirth and there's been
there's been like
a bunch of people
who i me and they're excited to meet me
and i'm like dude i feel like i get to
glean from you know like like danny
duncan like you know like yeah whatever
steve will do it you know like there's
all these
like these there's all these youtubers
who are just like
as successful as
like the top tier of
you know this wild how big
some of them have gotten
uh
it's crazy you've
you get all that love because people
care about you so much like the
inspiration you created us
you created us
it's rad that there's this that there's
this mutual
respect
and and like adoration
that's like so you know and and i'm just
it started with with my relationship
with you where like i uh
you know i just i knew i needed to start
over and i did and and you showed me the
way
and like you were my mentor you know and
and then i have i have a number of
relationships like that and i'm so so
grateful
that uh
you know that that
i could be teachable you know like it's
good for you for jumping in man you
really were one of the
the first to take that risk and that
jump i mean at your level
it wasn't even it i don't even think
that i i see it as a risk and i will
save it for your podcast what do you
what's the name of your podcast it's
just the roman atwood podcast man thank
god
i had so many names and everybody's like
it has to be smile more but i was like i
didn't want to turn the merch into the
podcast right yeah that's fine and then
i had roman atwood pranks roman with
vlogs it just felt right romney would
podcast dude there's nothing wrong with
it yeah i don't love or hate it it's
just the name
i mean
who reached out to who to get the vlog
going or to get your youtube channel
going i had um like an instagram vitali
i remember exactly where i was sitting
and what i was doing when you got on the
phone okay it was that special to me
yeah i was i was cloud nine i um
i i had i had met vitale without even
realizing it at one of my meet and
greets and at an early comedy club
before you and i even started working
together it would have been like 2011 or
2012 or
something maybe like 2013 but uh i'd
take pictures with the entire audience
after every show vitaly just happened to
be one of those people and his youtube
channel just blew up
with uh
his his profile picture was me and him
from the picture at my show
and uh i was in this
this spot in 2013
like trying to get something going and i
was like
you know i was kicking around an idea
where i was going to put together a team
of uh of like kind of jackass dudes and
and um so i was looking for like
pranksters on youtube and that led me to
to vitaly like hey i've got this project
and what what was crazy was that they
were like yeah we're kind of killing it
we don't really need to be like your
sidekick got a [ __ ] tv show and even
if they were willing
then i couldn't sell the show you know i
i i just couldn't tell the show and that
was where i was getting into a dark
place because
like i i lived in a in a a world i might
my
what was real to me was a world where i
needed permission from [ __ ] in suits
to green light some kind of project and
fund it for me to be able to do anything
and here these guys showed me
hey you know like with your tv show idea
like ah you know like whatever like
we're just doing youtube i just took a
[ __ ] on a basketball court and made 10
mil
we know nothing about tv that's all we
know yeah but at that time i didn't even
know that there was
like particularly money in making
youtube videos
there was less at that time too like
yeah we grinded for it for sure right
for sure but but so in any case i
somehow got a hold of vitale to try to
get him to be a part of a
tv show and at the time vitali and roman
were just this
duo just crushing it together like
and uh and and they
they uh
i made videos with each of them
with both of them for each of their
channels and they drove all that traffic
to my channel and i landed on youtube
like well it was one of the most
exciting things i got to do
really
did you hit a million subs in
i hit it was a i hit over a hundred
thousand subs in less than 24 hours yeah
which was which was wild because that
put you in the number one most subbed
for the day right something like that
yeah it was huge but you hit a million
quick no i mean reasonably quick yeah i
mean
compared to what we did
it's like brutal and then you were
flying to la to to do youtube i was
constantly back and forth from la like
two flights a week almost we were just i
gotta believe that for your podcast now
that it's going to make sense for you to
to make some trips to just go out there
and bank episodes we're in the works to
put a little studio right now yeah yeah
it's the only way to go it really is
we're gonna have to chase some people
down for sure yeah i mean like theo
vaughn's a good example of that he moved
out to nashville but he's in la like
shooting all this just back and forth
and and you can schedule it like
strategically so that you go in there
and just boom boom boom boom bang four
episodes you're good for the month yes
you know go out there once a month and
media manage for you yeah guests are the
you know you want i mean yeah that's the
deal yeah
um
yeah i'm stoked to be doing a podcast i
feel like i've uh i've personally fallen
in love with podcasts which took me a
while i didn't you know i'm a youtuber i
make youtube videos the short form
content and i slowly started listening
to podcasts i'm like i get this did it
trip me out when you said that you'd
listen to that you saw that david really
did yeah kidding me yeah man um
you guys are so crazy bro i'm like
sitting here wife and kids watching poop
this is two different worlds man
[Laughter]
that i was like super resistant to the
idea of jumping on the podcast bandwagon
just because i had been annoyed so many
times by the question will you be on my
podcast
you know i was just it was like no i
don't want every [ __ ] [ __ ] has a
podcast no i don't want to be on your
podcast with no [ __ ] audience wasting
an hour of my time to talk to three
people no that's not something i want to
do and then to turn around and be the
[ __ ] asking that question
oh god yeah you would have been primed
to ask you right you're such a started
uh funny it's so awesome to see theo
killing it um i was on his podcast back
when it was
in no video he just had like this
recorder in the room and everybody
talked into it you know it was like yeah
early days and it's just so cool to see
him kill him and he's such a funny dude
he's he's so natural
and uh
it's weird because now he's become like
this huge
like
huge theaters you know like he's like
he's at the highest level of
comedy dude i love hearing that yeah
and he's like it's it's it's just making
him uncomfortable being so successful oh
yeah he's such a hometown boy he's like
dude like i i'm not comfortable being so
successful and i'm like
okay buddy
yeah yeah
it's crazy man um
but the uh
the idea of podcast is is tough
but i'm so glad i did it and that was my
whole gimmick with the with the wild
ride like dude if i'm gonna be this
annoying guy let me say hey i'll bring
the studio to you
i love it i love it too because i see
this name
my god i wish i had a cool name this is
so cool and it's on your bus it's like
the coolest thing ever yeah i'm super
happy
whenever i look at the at the sign it
just gets it it goes absolutely man
um but yeah the like the the
getting guests is so stressful and
anxiety-inducing
like when you when you just came on the
bus i was like dude we need great guests
yeah yeah it's it definitely i'm i'm
eight episodes in right so i know i'm
like i'm counting all these people i
know personally and then it's like i'm
gonna run out right i'm gonna run out
then i gotta start bringing on people
that the other hard thing is i have an
audience
so i wan i wanna bring people on that
i'm interested in but my audience has no
clue who they are right and that's where
it gets tough it gets really tough
everybody in my audience knows you so
it's a naturally fun episode right right
but when i bring on a ufo expert that
nobody's heard of it's like i'm gonna
watch i aspire to get to that point
where like rogan can
bring on
whoever what a goal yeah what a guy
whoever and and i'm
at this point when like when we get
names suggested to us for podcast guests
i just got to think of like the health
of the podcast overall and i'm like man
is this a person that
that's that's gonna do good numbers is
this gonna be yeah it's a business it's
tough it's a business right feels like
every episode is either going to help
the health of the podcast or hurt the
health of the podcast and sometimes like
i i i have just done guests because i
love them yes and and and i fear that
it's hurt the podcast but then again
it's it also
i mean i don't know it's it's just i
obviously overthinking it now yeah
exact same way i had i had a good body
on my uh two episodes ago love the guy i
just genuinely love my worst numbers
right and coming out the gate you don't
want no bad numbers you're like i want
half a million every episode right right
yeah it's like 120 but dude you told me
you had vitali on and that just tripped
me out now let me be completely honest i
thought going into a podcast with roman
atwood that it would be super uncool to
even bring up vitaly because he's been a
controversial figure in recent times
i was shocked as hell to learn that
roman was
was
like
communicating with him at all let alone
having modest podcasts but i think
that's great and you know what else i
think is great is just being healthy man
taking care of your health knowing
what's going on with your health which i
do with my whoop band
if you haven't heard of these yet and
you've been living under a rock because
it is the most highly sophisticated
fitness tracking device ever invented
it works with this cool app on your
phone and it tells you
so much information about how much
you're sleeping what kind of sleep
you're getting how many disturbances you
have how much time spent in different
stages of sleep how your heart's pumping
what your respiratory respiratory system
is working like how much oxygen is in
your blood like
what kind of exercises you're doing how
well you're recovering from the exercise
i'm telling you it goes on and on and on
whoop is where it's at with fitness man
and they're offering the listeners of
the wild ride podcast not only 15
off your membership at checkout if you
use the promo code stevo but they're
giving you the whoop 4.0 band with the
waterproof everything charger included
for free if you sign up for a woop 4.0
membership it's the best thing man i
mean i love it you're gonna love it so
go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and use the promo code stevo for
15 off at checkout thank you whoop i
love you
thank you wild ride listeners i love you
too now let's talk about vitaly
like uh you said he's been sober for
eight months here's the thing uh yeah
i'm a little biased i love this kid like
i want to see vitaly do great right
so i had him on my show he told me he's
been sober we had lots of talks leading
up to it and look it's controversial
sure but it also makes great podcasts
right of course everybody hating on him
right now also wants to hear it so it's
been a very successful episode but at
the same time i got to witness and i
think the viewers really did too a new
vitality eight months sober
the vitali we know couldn't sit for an
hour hour and a half and do this he
couldn't right he would be pooping on
your table or doing the helicopter right
he's just the craziest human i know and
i tell him that all the time i mean
isn't it
like i mean i i don't know but i just
kind of got this sense that
you went pg
that made sure you did the natural-born
pranksters movies together but kind of
about that time
like you went your own way
and and if it's it felt like you kind of
needed to distance yourself from vitaly
we definitely went separate ways
mainly no reason whatsoever friendship
wise love the kid my whole
time i've known him love him it's it was
tough to watch him kind of
like like before like the big thing with
the arrest like it was like he
we were watching the wheels fall off and
it was tough you know and it makes sense
that you can't [ __ ] with the guy when
he's in self-destruct mode
yeah i definitely never uh
felt like i left this side in any case
but i certainly like went a different
direction you know i came back to ohio
and filmed with my kids and right i
couldn't keep up with the
i couldn't party anyway i was editing
every night right i don't remember you
ever partying i couldn't because i was
uploading every day and i was the editor
and the cameraman so it was like it was
also my excuse not to party and keep my
family strong it was like
11 o'clock at night gotta edit this
video man it's like but it's so it's so
interesting to hear you say that that
vlogging creating videos
like and keep my family strong in the
same sentence
like right doesn't it
like how much stress does the constant
cameras and vlogging like
i think i think brittany and i just
talked about this recently i don't think
we went to bed together for almost three
years
because because i would edit till 3 a.m
she would get the kids to bed she would
go to sleep and i would just
i was so
dedicated 100
to the time i wake up it's what i'm
filming and i also had to try to one-up
it every day i went as hard as i could
sure um to the time i just passed out on
the couch usually while i was uploading
it's not good for your
[ __ ] health
absolutely destroyed me you know what's
crazy i didn't know it until i stopped i
was like on a snowball but when i
stopped it took me
it really it aged me so hard man what do
you i don't see it man
i'm furious i don't know i'm working out
hard like you did at this age but i was
like i'm furious with how young you look
at 39.
well i'll be honest brit shaved all the
grays off last night i was like they
glisten in the light man
yeah so i was like uh under the hat it's
it's terrible but i was like just enough
to cover the house yeah
i got a ton of grays and we're the same
age
but your skin looks good you're doing
saunas you said lots of sauna i'm also
doing the red light yeah i don't know if
you mess with that i love it what's
breaking me out still a kid is caffeine
man okay how to get off the couch that
reminds me i remember like we went out
to dinner one night and you're like oh i
just watched this documentary about
sugar i'm off sugar
yeah how long did that last was i doing
that at that time dude you were like
sugar-free i think i made it 14 days
it was the hardest thing ever never felt
better in my life by the way went right
back to sugar it's not dude it's not
it's the most gnarly drug on the planet
i i'm in a 12-step program for
just that detoxing the [ __ ]
overeaters anonymous my my wife does
that i said that at a public level my my
my wife does uh like 72 hour bone broth
fast have you done my girl just did that
lux just did that what happened
just helps you detox mainly your gut
because your gut controls what you want
to eat a lot so you're getting off carbs
and sugars and
bone broth dude i mean she's my girl
said just a liquid diet she can have
like basically soup i think like yeah
yeah broth since yeah yeah like uh juice
you know whatever but just no solid food
it's amazing dude i do all the time i do
at least once a month i do a 24 hour
nothing fast nothing no water nothing
yeah you're looking lean you're looking
good yeah i'm trying i can't gain weight
though it's a problem with the way i'm
eating so i got to step it up you can
hang out with us for a week
when i travel i've been on a two-week
hiatus i haven't eaten this bad for a
long time but when i'm traveling it's
amazing it's athletic greens man yeah
it's one of my favorite podcast sponsors
and i literally swear by it dude you got
a packet of uh [ __ ] you pour in a pint
of water in the morning and it's like
comprehensive nutrition
um i can't even imagine like the stress
on your family with all the working but
the obvious question to me is
why do you do your own editing
listen man this is a trap that i don't i
can't even answer it you know what it is
i started filming the reason i bought a
camera was to edit i really enjoyed
editing so i think there's this weird
part of me that's like i can create it
the way i want i regret it every night
every night i'm sitting there the
family's going to bed and i'm like how
to knock this video out you're still
doing the editing i still edit
to steve quite a bit i mean like here's
the thing like i have an editor but i am
like the gnarliest like
over-the-shoulder nightmare for that
like i mean i'm in the i spend like way
too much time in the bay and like but at
least i got somebody to get it into like
decent shape i'm not like putting it in
there to begin with and creating the
timeline and sucking it up and like yeah
so i come in after the fact the biggest
step uh the biggest new thing is i have
somebody chopping the podcast
at least to its final form and then i go
through and i just dude like with the
podcast you can't really and it's easier
to edit because it is a production
multicam it's it's it's it is what it is
right yeah with vlogging it's like did i
make do i look stupid an editor might
not catch it right i know if i look
stupid because i'm judging you don't
look stupid can you really hand somebody
your baby right and i have tried it and
i have done it uh many times
currently i'm just rocking it dude
it's insane
the work ethic is is insane
um now let me ask about this this
fulfillment operation and because this
is our wheelhouse dude we love it we we
have two warehouses down in san diego it
started as one and we were just doing
great so we needed more space we got the
the next warehouse over beautiful and
we we call our fulfillment business
tight box packing
tight boxing i get it
we love it we love it and uh our
aspiration was to be like a fulfillment
center with third-party clients kind of
like a ship bob or like you know
whatever
i think that
now that we're
almost two years into it like the the
sheer volume that you have to do as a
third-party fulfillment center
is so staggering
that uh and the technology you need to
like start getting the the software so
sophisticated that can handle
multi-people multi businesses doing it i
feel as like kind of backing off of it
like like we
like we love our clients we've got like
we we've fulfill orders for tony hawk
like you know certain stuff that he says
yeah we've got like the the jackass guys
you know even dick house the production
company we've fulfilled their merch
so that's huge
i mean it's just not like well there
comes a point where it's like okay do we
want to go ape [ __ ] on it and start
getting clients or do you want to keep
it like it is in-house and
for it to make sense business-wise we
would need to have
hundreds if not thousands of uh of
clients we think because
holy smokes
i mean right now you can you're talking
amazon now yeah well that like if we had
about like
a hundred to a thousand clients
like you the the thing about fulfillment
i don't know if it's different for you
guys but like you're gonna
have to reinvest a lot of money in the
technology so you're constantly
constantly losing money
and you're buying more space you're
buying
more equipment but you're going into
debt to grow to grow to grow
debt debt get new funding and then
get a big payout by somebody to pick you
up like that's kind of the name of the
sell later yeah i think that the other
piece of it is that our model is we like
all of our clients keep 100
of all of their you know there's no
split
wow you know we're just we're just in
the shipping business i wonder you're in
debt
[Laughter]
like a fine model you got there the
teespring model is uh a little bit more
middle of the road yeah
but um but yeah we love it too but like
we i just love it because it's like a
fun clubhouse so fun it's so fun i
you know we did merch we were die hard
do it all my motto is keep it small keep
it all it was like we keep it all in we
make all the profits we our families
running it was uh
it's just such a unique thing and we we
did in this little building
it's like 700 thousand orders we moved
out of that building so it was to me a
massive success and we've just picked up
we've we've that building meaning your
garage my garage we moved seven hundred
thousand just a hair under seven hundred
thousand orders with uh friends and
family what about the like the the data
you know because i remember when i was
at maker studios they did my merch and
they kept all the email addresses from
everybody yeah
the data is like like arguably the most
valuable stuff data's gold because once
you have that email list right so did
you keep just a hair under 700 000
emails or so we definitely had a half a
million yeah we had a half a million
emails yeah and dude oh dude this is the
question i'm dying to ask because we've
how and why is it so
goddamn expensive to hire somebody to to
manage an email list and
what about sending out an email costs so
god damn much money it's so expensive
right especially when you get to a half
a million emails like these companies
charge
crazy amounts to
they they have you you profit off them
though right it's like i mean i mean
i don't know about some people get
pissed off at like you know i just i'm
so protective of of my audience that
like we hired a mass email guy and he's
just like oh yeah i'm gonna throw a
shirt on here like we're going to buy my
shirt i'm like dude i can't send out an
email to a mass audience without giving
them
some
piece of content something about it
that's like makes them glad they opened
it so i just would would
not let anything go out until i had the
piece of content ready and i'm just too
busy to be thinking about
so i could go a whole month paying this
guy
so much money and not even send out any
emails because i didn't approve anything
i'll be honest we sat on our email list
probably for
four or five years before my brother
came to me and he said you should be
sending emails i know what it was dude
we we're literally learning as we go on
all this stuff
same exact thing you pay a fortune to
send the emails we would go six months
without sending an email like we just
wouldn't and you'd be paying for this
email right
uh so
exactly yeah i eventually just got my
brother my brother's a whiz at this
stuff and he would help me out and i
would just record a 30 second video for
that email saying hello yeah it was
something personal
i did very few of them i never
capitalized on the emails
is your brother using uh
clavio as the i don't know man we might
need to we we might need to talk to your
brother anytime man he'd love to help
you yeah help you guys any time
so what other kind of like business you
know you got the the fulfillment and uh
yeah that one's very exciting to me um
and now part owner of that company me
and matt um and his wife own the company
and i'm just stoked by texas is that
like a tax thing no it's just where he
started the company he's he's really
built this company and
they've done all the hard work they
really have and
part of his he's wanted smile more to be
a part of that company forever five
years and i just brother i just do it
myself like it's my bread and butter it
really is smile moore's income
outweighed all my income like more than
you two more than that's my bread and
butter
um so
to get smile more there we we worked out
an ownership deal so
which is very exciting to me because i
love the merch world i love that i get
to grow a company now not just smile
more but a company what's the name of
the company bunker branding oh yeah um
really fun place like you said it's a
clubhouse right it's a clubhouse like i
want i want to put a a podcast there in
the bunker where in texas san antonio
okay yeah
great hub and uh
just been so fun for me dude and uh
buying some properties investments and
just things that my kids will probably
sell one day and right yeah like just
setting things aside and
why not
yeah man did real estate that it's crazy
like we're like growing up and like
yeah dude we have a podcast that's how
you know we're growing up um i don't
know that the pod podcast is a benchmark
of anything i don't know
just talking i feel like five years ago
i would have never thought about a
podcast now i'm like it is fun though
i can sit and chill with somebody i
really love and just chat
it's fun like fascinating conversations
with like
exciting people i really enjoy it i
really enjoy it i feel like my heart's
happy doing it and i haven't had that
for a while man like i i i swear i look
at my vlog camera some days i want to
throw up like i really don't know
bro what kind of camera are you using
these days for vlogging dude i'm not
gonna lie i'm still rocking a g7x
now i did just recently get a a7 a sony
right but it's so darn awkward yeah it's
clunky casey
killed it with them big cameras man and
i never made the move i just
you know but you can see it my quality
sucks dude
g7x is it up to like g7x like six or
excuse me i think they're still rocking
the g7x like
i think they keep updating it but right
it's still a hot camera
that's great yeah wait i remember i
remember you were the first person i saw
with the little little baby dead cat on
there yeah dude i really
think i started that man i remember
being at vidcon or something guys like
jesse wellins is like what's going on
there was like windscreen i don't know
why nobody thought of that because my my
videos are oh god right right right
right gotta get a windscreen on here
yeah
do you have uh have you ever gotten into
touring like it seems to me it would
make sense for you to have done that i
did uh a fantastic tour we were killing
it big theaters sold out with fousey oh
okay i remember him and i did a real fun
like 40 show tour a little bit of europe
in europe you know is so fun the fans
are so fun in europe um
that was like my only tour we did a
little one for uh natural born
pranksters um
talk about awkward dude cause that movie
was rated r i had already made the pg
switch but the movie took so long to
come out was all these families and kids
showing up and i'm like this is like
hard arc dave england's pooping right on
a canvas and making a painting out of it
i'm like looking at these parents like
i'm so sorry like wow what am i gonna do
like
and and wasn't that
like uh
i seem to recall that like on the
financial end of that didn't it kind of
become a debacle like like
so
tally and i just had this conversation
on the podcast okay because now it's a
joke but at the time
i was the only one that said i'm not
doing the money without i'm not doing
the movie unless i get money up front
right period because dude i kind of know
the biz i was like i don't know
like yeah we're in our prime but
we're on youtube like i don't know how
movie or tv is going to do for us so i
wasn't doing it for a hundred grand
which come on it was like
they were selling it was this big
hollywood movie right and i'm like
that's fine if it's such a success
you guys take the back end just give me
the 100k up front you know so that's
what we worked out and uh dennis and
vitali ragged me so hard bro like you're
the biggest idiot blah blah long story
short they both got z version
wow so now it's a fun joke vitale's like
you're the only one with a brain now you
know and yeah but yeah i wasn't asking
but in that biz it's just always the
budget for that i mean 100k compared to
what the but it hadn't been like a good
question i think it was a good one or
two one five or something yeah for us it
was a fun budget right how is it working
with barry smaller
you know what i loved barry he like he
he was our jackass guy that's right yeah
so you so you uh like smart move for you
to make that movie to to take our uh we
were poaching hard dude we were coaching
hard dude uh no but
i learned a lot at the end of the day i
just learned a lot it was a fun
experience um and it was cool to be able
to pull up netflix or something and see
my movie yeah that's cool right but at
the end of the day my youtube was way
more successful and it wasn't like it's
it's tough i think the sense that i got
was that you're putting so much into
youtube
that to try to make another project
it's like one's gonna suffer at the
hands of the other absolutely did i
remember my vlogs dropping about 100k an
episode by the end of the month it was
it was a big drop
um and i remember that being a huge
issue i was like guys i'm this is a
sacrifice for me youtube is uh what do
you call it a
jealous god yeah
yeah they'll take from you fast man
yeah that's what uh danny trejo said
that uh fighting like boxing you know or
any like combat sports it's a jealous
god like where if you think you're gonna
like you know if you think you're gonna
be trying to have a movie career or
something you know like that dog you
take your attention away from fighting
and then your fighting's gonna yeah i
learned i learned quick about
you know you my daily vlogs became the
gold
uploading every day five million a pop
if i did anything after five i remember
every day i remember seeing your [ __ ]
vlogs
i remember for some reason it was like 2
million like 24 hours yeah and that was
the impossible that was like we're never
getting bigger and then we were getting
a five to six mil a day god damn it was
a nightmare but i had
24-hour police officers here at this
house for five years
five years is it was maybe one and a
half two million dollars i had in
security
wow yeah dude it was wild
wild that's insane it was an absolute
nightmare
where i'm at right now is a very happy
place it is i know it sounds crazy um
but it's very happy place it's chill
it's like we have a nice audience that
that loves to hear us and i think i've
always felt like
you know but for me
um
and like i i've been sort of uh big
enough of uh you know success to to live
comfortably but i've never had like
paparazzi chasing me you're not like i
can i can
i remember coming out and you just
bought your place yeah the day i got
there they published it
and i'm like
nightmare man i'm like i can't even
imagine but i think a lot of my security
and this stuff comes from having little
ones man having my kids like i think if
it was me and the wife it's like that
will defend ourselves but i did not take
any risks man yeah that's great full
security
really just at home yeah you know
especially with me traveling so much it
was just like whatever it takes like
whatever it takes like just to have
peace of mind so now have you had enough
kids
i ain't in mexico yet so you know she's
not having another one bro it's it's
wild cause the age gap yeah i literally
keep starting over my oldest is 17 my
newest is one and a half wow so i have
this wide range and i have a beautiful
four-year-old and a ten-year-old and
it's the greatest thing in my life but
it is a wide range of humans you know i
have every age it's like
how's um
like like your relationship is it's
crazy to see your instagram like like
you're all dressed up like are you going
to church on sunday like you're dressed
up like that like i i love church man i
do i've
i've found so much joy and peace and
just hoping my life through it it really
has helped me a lot um and and i i
didn't grow up without it i watched my
mom and dad become part of it kind of in
their 30s 40s and i watched them
quit drinking quit smoking
and i watched them kind of
just be a good example maybe it was
church maybe it was just them aging
um but i remember thinking like i really
want that for my children in my life and
uh yeah
so going to a little church here and
there and uh man it really connected
with me i fell in love with it man
that's cool that's epic dude fell in
love with it and uh
just had some weird things happen in my
life that maybe some would just consider
coincidence but i feel it's just pure
blessing man like really the hand of god
oh well dude
like they're like yeah
i feel very strongly in
activity behind the curtain love it to
which we are not privy at how the
universe is
genuinely conspiring something going
on
something going on 100 the hand of god
and and like i would you know we could
talk about this on on your podcast but
i i
religiously meditate
for i maintain an average of over 40
minutes every single day meditating
for
over 930 straight days oh wow yeah
that's beautiful man i spent like 600
hours meditating since uh 2019. what do
you do when you meditate is it it's a
mantra it's a very uh quiet silence
you're working right
i mean
like uh
it's mantra based so like that same as
like a transcendental meditation
vedic meditation and uh and and i i'm
terrified of ever not doing it
interesting because i genuinely believe
that
that it it has formed a relationship
with the universe i am plugged in to
some type of other power and [ __ ] an
intelligent [ __ ] order of the
universe that is conspiring in my favor
i love it man
i think that we all find things and and
you know as man you know
there's just times where you just
shouldn't be alive
oh yeah you have survived there is
somebody watching over here
so man i love hearing that that's cool
yeah i have strong spiritual beliefs man
i have an unshakable faith and and i
genuinely believe that
whether it's going to church whether
it's meditating whether it's just like
being mindful to not do harm and to be a
generous human being a good human that
that brings about
like
some kind of respect for
the universe for for life for
you know being thankful yeah like like
that that's
a really big [ __ ] thing that's what
we're here for you know
so uh
with that said i think that what we need
to do is send some traffic to each other
now if you guys want to hear the
continuation of this where i might
actually start crying because i'm so
[ __ ] grateful i'm gonna i'm gonna
walk everybody's through
how dark my life got and and the the the
significance
of
of you and i coming together almost 10
years ago now this is a myth this just
blows my mind first of all i'm pumped to
hear it yes this blows my mind i didn't
know this this was the effect i did not
know so i'm i i have a book coming out
in september which i urge everybody to
pre-order
uh you can and that's the only way to
get a signed hardcover copy is to
pre-order it and you can do that at
stevo.com
and uh man the book gets really it
doesn't come out till september so
you're gonna get the well
that's like boom yeah that's true that's
a boom get it now
yeah get it now but um everybody we're
gonna switch over to the roman atwood
podcast thank you guys for having me
everywhere podcasts are available
and on youtube yes sir
and uh and and we're particularly
interested in our spotify listeners yes
yeah we're working on uh something fun
for them for this particular episode
yeah i got something exciting so so i
think we might see a little bump in our
spotify action
and uh yeah man dude it's [ __ ]
all right
that uh that that worked great
so there you have it folks if you're
even still sticking around because i
know that everybody is hauling ass to go
listen to the roman atwood podcast which
i recorded with him right after this but
before you race off let me just thank
you for sticking around to the end
my beautiful street team that i'm so
grateful for
um
what can i say man i love you guys and
thank you